what if we could create organizations
where everybody led where everybody had
uh authentic strong
voice
wouldn't
organizations perform better in that
approach but even more importantly
wouldn't um
that serve humanity better
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
let's talk about lumber yes lumber meet
kevin hancock chief executive officer of
hancock lumber company
kevin hancock is an award-winning author
and speaker the ceo of hancock lumber
company one of the oldest and best known
family businesses in america he is a
recipient of the ad muskie access to
justice award the habitat for humanity
spirit of humanity award and boy scouts
of america distinguished citizen award
and the timber processing magazine
person of the year award
kevin is also a member of the maine
indian tribal state commission he is a
frequent visitor to the pine ridge
indian reservation in south dakota kevin
is an advocate of strengthening the
voices of all individuals within a
company or community through listening
empowering and shared leadership kevin
is also the founder of the seventh power
and non-profit organization dedicated to
advancing economic sovereignty for
native communities across america
kevin hancock welcome to 20 minute
leaders how you doing
michael i'm
doing great thanks for having me
thank you very very much for joining me
on another episode of 20 minute leaders
i i love these episodes because these
episodes always leave me with so much
inspiration i go in there thinking we're
going to be talking about one thing and
it always ends up say you know on on
this crazy journey your your personal
journey is remarkable and i think it's
so fascinating and and i'm really
curious to hear about your own insights
especially given the book
that that you wrote and your personal
experiences beyond the fact that you're
the chief executive officer of a lumber
company uh of i believe uh for two
centuries this company's been in
existence right
yes that's right it's one of the oldest
companies in
america we're in our seventh generation
of company goes back to the 1840s
incredible unbelievable so this is the
def you're definitely
you know the leader that is running the
longest the oldest company that i've had
on this show and so already i'm
extremely honored thank you very much
and to get things out of the way um tell
me a little bit about you know you is
you know your voice right now because i
want to get this out of the way so that
we can now put this in context the
experience that you've had which is
obviously a big pillar in your book as
well in the context of your great you
know leadership journey and the personal
journey that you've been on sure so in
uh 2010
at the peak of the
national housing and mortgage
market collapse i quite suddenly began
to have trouble speaking something i'd
always take it for granted and honestly
michael is a ceo done a lot of you know
when you think about it
uh in some ways your ceo your voice is
your tool it's what you use and suddenly
i couldn't
really use it it turned out i've
acquired a
rare neurological voice disorder that
i've never heard of called spasmodic
dysphonia
i've gotten quite a bit better at the
time there's no way i would have been
able to do the show with you i literally
couldn't force out more than a few
broken sentences at a time and it became
really difficult for people
to hear me all the time and so
on very short notice in a bit of
economic crisis
yet to come up with a with quite a
different approach to leading
wow i can i can only imagine so you know
before we get to the leading painting
the picture of of you know where you are
2010 you know you're in the greatest
housing crisis i believe ever you know
starting over in 2007 7 lumber company i
guess it was affected quite a bit from
that experience
what's happening
yeah so the lots of pressure on our
industry our company
operates on
16 sites across
maine at new hampshire we have sawmills
lumber yards and over 600
people work at the company and in 2010
backing up two years in the span of
about 24 months
our revenue fell by 50 percent half cut
in half
without losing a customer just the
economy
shrunk that dramatically that quickly so
it was
uh really stressful long story short
i i can only imagine and so
you're going then going through this
experience and your your voice is
changing your ability to lead
through voice is different and you're
mentioning that you have to harness
different tools
take me back to that exact moment you
know is it is it scary is it stressful
is it confusing all of the above what's
going on through your mind as a leader
yeah it blows everything you just
mentioned it was stressful it was
confusing
but like humans tend to do in difficult
situations you just
you fight and and you don't really know
the way out but you just
dig in so at first
well to keep it real simple what i ended
up doing is this
when it's hard to talk
you quickly come up with strategies for
doing less of it
if my
strategy
that just materialized was essentially
at work to answer a question with a
question
thereby putting the conversation right
back on the other person so picture this
michael someone would come up to me at
work
with question or problem because it was
the ceo and in
i would give it an answer and directive
and instructions but now i couldn't
really do that
so this is what i started saying i
started saying
simply
wow that's a great question what do you
think we should do about it
wow
i love that
what uh struck me over time now mind you
at first i was doing that just to
protect my voice but here's what struck
me over time it changed the way i
thought about leadership
after having asked that question
hundreds of times what i started to
realize was this people actually already
knew what to do
it turned out they didn't they almost
never actually needed instruction or
direction from above
all they really needed
was the encouragement
and the safety
in terms of the culture for them to
trust
their own voice
i i love it i love it so i actually
discovered
by
you know encouraging them to you know to
speak more and to voice their opinions
they actually came up with the solutions
themselves probably giving them more
courage for the for future times and
you're actually creating leaders within
them and enabling them to take more
proactivity and more action action-based
behavior right
right
this is where i started to actually get
quite excited about what happened to me
and i can't see
my own voice limitations
as a bit of a gift an invitation
to strengthen the voices of others
and
that's when i got really interested in
inverting the traditional leadership
model
which typically collects power
and i get really interested in this idea
of dispersing power and
what if we could create organizations
where everybody led where everybody had
uh authentic strong
voice
wouldn't organizations perform better
in that approach but even more
importantly
wouldn't um
that serve humanity better
right
now for people around you
you know as they're experiencing this
shift and obviously you're changing as a
leader they're changing as micro leaders
within these organizations in different
hierarchies how are they responding to
this is this a natural you know behavior
that they may not even have realized
that is happening you know are they do
they do you then see them go and employ
that with others in their domain what
what what shifts are happening within
your company
yeah it definitely took a while because
the traditional model of leadership and
followership is so deeply ingrained in
almost everybody from childhood right up
through school and then into the world
of work
but
uh
once
we stuck with you know stuck with it
over a period of years it tipped quite
quickly and i thought a lot about why
michael and
uh here's what i've concluded that new
leadership model of dispersing power is
really much more aligned
with how nature actually works
and
flows i had a bit of an epiphany in the
uh nevada excuse me the arizona desert
one evening i was watching um
sunset and these five words
plopped into my head in nature power is
dispersed and i looked around at that
desert scene and i said out loud i have
leadership chat with the with the
environment around me i said where's the
capital of this desert where's its
headquarters where's the ceo where are
all the managers and the supervisors and
i actually looked at a small group of
cactus and said which one of you is in
charge of all the others
and in every case as you know the answer
was self-evident the leadership power of
nature is dispersed in all its pieces
big and small and humans who are a part
of nature not detached from it
ultimately aspire i believe
to organize
in that same way
incredible i i can i can literally
picture you in the arizona desert
sitting there and and and seeing this
unfold and i can only imagine you know
the intrinsic
feeling of under of truly understanding
it and embracing it and not just list
hearing it in a business school lecture
but actually experience it firsthand now
where's once you started transitioning
to your new voice into your new
leadership style
you also went on a personal journey
right that that that changed the way
that you think about the world around
you and you know your priorities what
was that journey like for you
yeah in 2012
i
began traveling from maine where i lived
in the northeast corner of the country
out to the pine ridge indian reservation
in the southwest corner of south dakota
pine ridge's
the biggest most historic most
traditionally disenfranchised
today the poorest yet beautiful in so
many ways of all the suit reservations
on northern plains it's a place i've now
been over two dozen times i go back
twice a year and
lots of friends there here
what's the first big connection at pine
ridge i met an entire community that did
not feel fully heard that felt as if a
piece of their authentic voice had been
taken or stolen from them
and because of my own voice conviction
in the oddest of ways it struck a chord
with me and it got me thinking about the
history of
leadership and i concluded unfortunately
over time
that leaders
through history have probably done more
historically
to limit restrict direct and
manage the voices of others
then to free them
and that's really when it hit me my
voice was an invitation
to try to model something very different
i i love it i i just love the insights
and i love how you know you're you're
looking at your role as a leader and
you're very intentionally saying you
know where instead of you know
you know harnessing harnessing power and
then embracing the power you're actually
saying okay let's disperse it and let's
create micro leaders and and and and
have them be in the same mindset that
you know their leadership is not
measured by how much power they can gain
by how much power they can then continue
to disperse and to motivate others i
think that's that's incredible kevin i
have to uh hear about what it's like to
run a lumber company you know i'm coming
from the tech world and most the guests
are in the tech world but you know
you're running a company and and it's
you know it's more than 200 years old
what is that what is that like you know
what yeah
what is it
like
well it's uh it's fascinating
and complex and yet simple all at the
same time so two thoughts come to mind
one it's
really cool at this day and age to work
with a natural resource
that's renewable recyclable and
biodegradable it's just a
great
environmental
product
second the other thing that really
strikes me over time is just the uh the
history or the longevity of keeping a
company
going
across
multiple generations and through
multiple transitions if i made a list of
all the events
that were gonna be the demise of our
company
just my lifetime from
uh
globalization to the age of walmart to
the internet uh you know all of it that
you really
have to be an entrepreneur
in any company whether it's new or old
because you're constantly reinventing
yourself
right how do you ignite innovation
in a field like lumber when you're
seeing you know this transformation that
is happening around you
whether it be walmart globalization 3d
printing you know you mentioned you have
to be an entrepreneur in a company that
is you know incredibly incredibly old
how do you even begin to then you know
can talk to the board of directors talk
to your employees to the other
leadership and say listen guys we have
to be on top of what's happening in the
world here because we have to remain
relevant
right great question it's really i think
about culture and keeping
a healthy
sense of urgency and the right dose of
paranoia
about
your business and as everyone at
business knows no matter what you've
done in the past
the focus has got to stay on where
you're going
in the
in the future we kept saying we use at
our company that is simply this always
changing to remain the same so what
makes the same ideally are our court
values
but everything about how we manufacture
logistics engage customers engage
employees handle products all of that
constantly has to be up for grabs
but to the point we're discussing today
with you spurs power and get everybody
thinking about leading change change
becomes so much easier because it's
happening organically
across the organization it's not being
pushed through it it's just flowing
through through the company
i i love it kevin take me back a little
bit to your own upbringing your own
childhood even you know 10 years old
elementary school middle school what are
you really curious about what what
sparks your interests yeah interestingly
not i was fascinated even then with the
american west i remember playing on the
floor at my grandparents house with
cowboys in india something
you know you probably wouldn't even see
today but i was really fascinated
by the idea of a frontier
that really when i got a little older
historically fascinated by the second
half of the 19th century
when our nation's quote-unquote manifest
destiny
ran into
the plains
tribes
uh that that period
just
is
human history in in a in a nutshell to
me a microcosm and it all fascinates me
beautiful and if you look at your life
today whether it's professional or
personal where do you draw your
inspiration on a daily basis where do
you look out for when you need
inspiration for what to do and when to
do it
to the human spirit
it's a broad answer but i see it
everywhere i see
i'm blessed to really see
the innate beauty and sacred power of
the human spirit and you can find that
in everyone it lives in everyone and
when you see the world that way you're
really
surrounded
by inspiring people
beautiful i love it if you were to
think of a few words
that would describe kevin hancock or
that anybody around you would think of
when they think of kevin what what are a
few words that would come to mind
i would say or hope um
writhing
empowering
and
hopeful or optimistic
i can definitely see especially the
optimism you know shine through this
conversation and i'll leave you with one
last question
for me my friends you know you know
young entrepreneurs looking to become
good leaders not just start you know in
the tech world everybody's talking about
starting companies and being successful
and then making good technologies but
but few people talk about you know being
good leaders
and what does it mean to be a successful
leader so if you had to give
you know your own two cents on what
young entrepreneurs like myself we
should be
thinking about intentionally as we go
about our own entrepreneurial journey
and leadership journey what would that
be
that such a great question i i would say
again that leadership is really about
giving other people more power and the
human organizations
including corporations
should all have the same highest mission
which is to advance
humanity that humanity is advanced
in the end
one human at a time starting with the
people
right beside us
i love it kevin thank you very very much
this was wonderful and inspiring and
thank you for taking time and for your
energy and uh stay safe and stay healthy
and continue inspiring many many more
thank you i'm thankful we're connected
loved be with you today michael thank
you thank you very much
[Music]